hello and welcome to this video I'm
paying poor Luke again
so let's see again means I played played
him own name
some games perform no quick reply this
time okay yeah after is one of my my pet
peeves are complaining complaining is
wrong but kind of thick people playing
instant moves and positions where they
they should think I mean I have an
interesting idea here I come on it's
just a blitz game yeah the bishop takes
I take B to win they exchange for I mean
the position is kind of chaotic yeah and
here I get an age for which is probably
not really that great but yeah it's it's
it's funky let's let's do it
I have to admit that I made a very
simple had a very simple misconception
here I somehow forgot that this night is
covering if I never have a queen a five
idea to get the Queen over anyway so
he's taking really why why not just take
okay interesting
so he's sacrificing a pond so if I take
it he plays Queen d3 or
Wow tough to say right here how this
should be played
it's a very very unique position but I
felt it's I felt it cannot be that bad
if my king is on f7 so that I'm I can
more quickly get pieces on G and the G
file okay now Queen d7 rook c8 h - maybe
I should have played H - first
and let's do that perform before this
opportunity is it's not there anymore
Queen age three is not a good idea
I don't want to take this it's not so
much about like a double pawn or
something but giving after the pawn
takes the queen somehow gets more active
here like if this is here the Queen can
help in defense what an art position I
mean okay I am it is something that I
definitely am responsible for here with
my with my unusual plane okay now now
this one yeah let's just do that it's a
good move Knight is hanging and yeah
okay that's certainly a winning position
for black rook g1 is a is already very
hard yeah that it's already killing him
and that's it he's got no check and
queen edge one maid yeah at g5 probably
not the best daddy ever but it was funny
and what I really learned in in recent
years is that those aged five and aged
for ideas that looks so weird are not
really that exotic often that that this
kind of moves makes sense
in particular when there is no night
anymore on f3 like here the night is on
b3 and there is no cover of h4 and
whenever white does has some sort of
back some sort of drawback yeah not not
reacting is probably wrong like the
engine is kind of clearly stating and
also here like if if he does that I go
in chuan black is clearly better I just
have an h-file that I can use and there
are quick moves that that are possible
so he has to react in some way and it's
just that even this it has some
drawbacks if you play h3 it is not so
easy anymore to play the F pawn the same
for H form so this h5 is not this is not
very avant-garde or anything weird just
just normal nowadays it's a normal way
to play and okay Bishop e6 and now it
went with this g5 move which is probably
objectively dubious I don't know now I
have six or something 27 is normal and
the engine says equal with Bishop takes
g5 I mean I suspected that this could be
some kind of compensation because if we
if we look at this this is just an odd
position where I'm not sure where I'm
ever going with the King f6 I would
probably play and now from here Knight
you form with equal play according to
the engine
which is funny I mean Hawaii why does an
exchange down but it's a it's an odd
position now it no it gives black an
advantage show and this is very tough to
analyze them okay took with the pawn and
that gave me age four and now g4 is a
strange decision I thought should take
yeah so I captured this I mean we can't
look at the capture this I would have
just taken and the engine thinks I'm
fine
Bishop you should age 327 yeah it's I
mean the age file is open so here then
g6 was my reaction
okay then with age three that was kind
of tough I think yeah it gives me at
least a clear advantage according to the
comp so age three cake cake sugar three
Bishop takes wasn't accurate 27 now it's
okay
yeah maybe opening up the e-file is not
that great yeah yeah I was thinking he
should play a king age too maybe
I mean I have easy moves Queen d7 rope
GA but okay so this one night if for
yeah when tej tool also it's called a
bit of a my advantage here on IG three
it's clearly better for black but not
winning at least initially the engine is
just giving me a small edge oh wow
95 is a huge mistake what I mean that
this is a good move I'm I know yeah but
why is that bad let be to deform I did
not see that most at all wow I mean yeah
I'm also better here I mean I must be
yeah but it's not not as clear as the
other one okay
checkmate is unavoidable hey okay I
didn't see that one but it looks it
looks looks unavoidable okay guys thanks
for watching